macrón desde luego no quiere tirar
todavía la toalla con el líbano y quiere
que su iniciativa de formar gobierno
siga adelante y ha vuelto a presionar a
las autoridades libanesas para que
formen un gobierno entre 4 y 6 semanas
exactamente antes de las elecciones de
eeuu porque de lo contrario podría haber
más inestabilidad política macro y
occidente en general lo que quieren es
que el líbano tenga un gobierno fuerte
un gobierno independiente y no siempre
con las rivalidades hectáreas que es
precisamente lo que ha bloqueado este
gobierno y los gobiernos anteriores en
general macro no ha sido claro con
hezbollah y ha dicho que al mismo tiempo
no puede seguir siendo una milicia y
estar luchando en siria o declaren la
guerra israel y al mismo tiempo ser un
partido político centrado en los asuntos
nacionales en lugar de seguir siempre la
agenda iraní bueno y entonces como se
vive entre tanto en las calles este
fracaso nuevamente de la formación de un
gobierno en líbano
bueno desde la emisión de mustafa deep
este sábado han habido manifestaciones
no multitudinarias de libaneses tanto
beirut como las principales ciudades del
líbano exigiendo en este caso la
renuncia del presidente del parlamento
nabih berri y también del presidente
michel aún por este bloqueo a la
formación de un gobierno libanés
teniendo en cuenta que el líbano que los
libaneses están con el agua hasta el
cuello por la crisis económica más
inestabilidad política lo único que
podría traer es de nuevo una devaluación
de la moneda local que precisamente el
sábado cayó a un mínimo histórico de 8
mil 800 libras libanesas por un dólar lo
que significa que la economía
prácticamente está hundida que ha
perdido el 90 por ciento de su valor y
ahora mismo los libaneses están
intentando reponerse de la explosión del
puerto de beirut y con una economía tan
débil lo que no pueden aguantar más es
una inestabilidad política y que el
gobierno sigue dilatándose en el tiempo
que no se forme ya porque lo más
importante para que el líbano pueda
tener las ayudas internacionales es
precisamente la formación de este
gobierno gracias a ustedes